Kristen is with us in Green Bay hi
Kristen welcome today Ramsey show hole
in the surround you thank you for taking
my call
sure what's up about 177 thousand
dollars in debt I just got the power of
attorney so that I'm taking care of her
bills one of her three creditors has
transferred over her debt to a lawyer
and I I've heard you talk about
creditors and how to deal with them but
I don't know how to deal with a lawyer
on it now okay well it's a collections
attorney which is basically a collector
okay it's they're bottom-feeders so what
kind of debt is the 177 thousand 58 for
the mortgage I have about 6,000 for
their cars seven thousand for one
medical bill four thousand for another
medical bill and one thousand for
another medical bill okay how old is she
63 why are you now power of attorney
she's starting to forget stuff she's
tried getting checked out for dementia
she's in the process of doing that and
she hasn't been paying her stuff so I
put her on a budget and so now I'm
taking care of her stuff what is her
income she makes about 28,000 years
mm-hmm okay and what is the house were
hired sorry what's the house worth my
sister lives in it now and she's kind of
destroyed it I'm so much where's your
mother running an apartment your mother
is paying rent in an apartment so that
your sister can live in the house yeah
so what's the house worth I'm guessing
65 okay okay so how fastest are you
through
your sister out and selling the house
can't throw her she's on the deed I
can't throw her out are you on the deed
or not how did she get on the deed my
sister has a child with needs so my mom
wanted to make sure my niece had a place
to live so she put my sister on it are
you paying that is your mother paying
the mortgage yeah I told my sister I was
not anymore
yeah everything everything's in my mom's
name all the utilities everything is
tight Kumail yep I can't turn the heat
off I can't turn the utilities off
because the winter is coming your sister
can put the utilities in her name she
said that she can't because her deposits
too high mm-hmm because she doesn't tend
to pay her bills so they read for
deposit too you know
compensate for that but you can cease to
pay the bill right yeah okay she needs
to pay the bill yep and that's it and
seeks to pay the mortgage today okay I
just got rid of 58,000 of the debt good
and 101,000 and student loans passes
away when your mom passes away yep okay
so we don't worry about those quit
paying those paying the student quit
paying the student loans so now I gots
$11,000 in some medical bills yep his
the rest of it we're just not paying
your mom doesn't have any money she's
broke she's got parently got dementia
same as $28,000 a year she's 63 years
old she live in an apartment we have to
make sure she's cared for first and
that's food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities she doesn't
need transportation did you say there
was a car in here does she need to be
driving
I say no you're the power of attorney
yeah I know that I've tried to convince
her to sell her car and get a
thousand-dollar car because fifty eight
hundred dollars is a lot for a car so
it's not a lot for a car but it's a lot
for a car for somebody that has dementia
and I'm not sure they need to be driving
right
you can't remember to pay her bills can
she remember how to get home I'm scared
for her that was one of the poems she
forgot how did it get home that's what
started it is it responsible on your
part to let her drive the answer is no
right
she I love her you love her you don't
want her to be hurt or to hurt someone
for God's sakes she could she could go
driving off and end up in Tennessee from
Wisconsin and we'd have one of those
silver alerts or whatever they call them
right yeah yeah no I think we're gonna I
think we're gonna do away with cars
period oh okay now we're down to medical
bells these are very hard decisions for
you
but you have to do your job as the power
of attorney and as a loving daughter is
do things that are good for your mom
regardless of who it upsets your sister
is upset your mother's upset I don't
care it's very hard for you to make
those decisions but we're only going to
do things that are good for your mom
none of this you are doing is out of
greed for yourself okay so tell the
student loan people they get zip nothing
nada okay tell your sister she gets
nothing
not a zip sell the car now I'm down to
just a few medical bills and I think you
can work your way through those with her
income or at least get some kind of a
payment plan going that's very small and
you can let that attorney's office know
that basically she has no money what
women what is the $28,000 coming in from
she has a pension annuity and Social
Security okay
then what I probably would do with these
medical bills is let them know they're
probably not going to get paid either
except if I have a little extra money
here they're after taking care of mom
because I paid 50 on it last month on
each one that's okay if you won't pay 25
or something there if you can work out
some kind of lump sum and you know 500
bucks settles a whole debt or something
like that and clears them up that's fine
but here's the thing if they were to sue
her do you know what they're going to
get nothing because she you know what
she has nothing all of the income that
she has they cannot attach you can't
attach pension income you can't attach
social security income and you can't
attach an annuity and so that she's what
we call judgment proof because she's
broke and so that puts you in a very
strong position to talk to mr. or mrs.
collections bottom-feeder attorney when
you do talk to them and just go here's
situation she's 63 she's got dementia
she has no assets and her only income is
pension and Social Security
she's judgment-proof tell him I said
that only talk being a financial coach
and he said they're judgment-proof
okay and so what we'll do is we would
like to clear this up but we're going to
do it for pennies on the dollar so make
me a ridiculous offer because that's the
only way you're getting any money and
play hardball with them because we got
to take care of mom here I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to beat him by up I'm
not trying to hurt anybody I'm trying to
protect your mom and the last thing I
needed she gets her food paid her lights
and water her rent and she is taken care
of only then do we deal with a couple of
medical bills sell our car sister gets
nothing
student loan gets nothing so I'm I'm
saying this real kind of like because I
want you to get a little that down
inside because I know these are gonna be
hard conversations for you yeah
but you got to be are cuz it's your mom
you're protecting okay exactly
you can do it you can do it if you need
some help you call me back but just just
play hardball with them tell them she's
judgment-proof my goodness what a story
Wow
there's a reason to save for retirement
right there and you were not want to
retire bro save for retirement
there's a reason right there you just
hear it there it is right there that's
why you want to have half a million
dollars in your 401k when you get to
retirement right there it is instead of
buying that stupid car yeah hello hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]